okay welcome to the next video in the
repertoire series which will be about
them the main noun suggestion against
the Kings Indian which is the move oops
not d5 it is to move five f3 which is
the same issue a variation named after a
German Grandmaster castles and now it's
the first interesting parting of the
ways because white has to choose move
six and almost six there are three main
options um that's the outline so to say
the classical move which is Bishop e6
this move is also still very much
playable of course it is found a bit
into into disuse because of the pawn
sacrifice c5 which is I think a bit
surprising if you see it at the first
time black sacrifices this pawn this is
the the starting point and now White has
a couple of moves available at move ten
Bishop e3 e3 92 and so on is Triton a
lot of a lot of moves
interestingly on even with modern day
computer system that seems that black
has some enough compensation based on
his slight development advantage to not
so his ideas of playing on the dark
squares one constant issue of this kind
of pancetta was pawns on c4 on e4 and
the D pawn gun is the weakness on
default so this pawn red line has fallen
a bit into disuse and white doesn't have
so many alternatives here so white began
looking at-at other
and one move which is also my
recommended line is not G - E - this is
flexible move because you don't yet come
at the commit to Bishop to e3 or g5 and
you can choose one of the two squares
depending on what black is is playing
next one important point here is that
actually the usual move for the Kings
Indian f5 is not so good here Bishop g5
is a good answer and one possible line
there is some c6 between e2 not bt7 and
then d5 CT xt v CT CT xt v then maybe a
6 g 4d 593 this is a pretty typical
position if black plays d5 and it's a
position that simply is is better for
white no question because of a nice
space advantage the setup was g4 and not
g3 really takes out a 5 of the position
black will never be able to play this
and with the kingside safely blocked
white can easily concentrate on playing
on the Queen side once idea is not to
castle long and then launch an attack
but rather play quietly like Bishop e2
and then maybe even short casts and our
King F 2 - 2 - G - and then play on the
Queen side it's a very nice position if
v is really a bit of a dubious move so
what does black play if if v is not not
the greatest here yeah they're actually
two moves that are played most often
here first one
is Knight to c6 and in this position
white has a choice of Bishop g5 and e3 I
actually would recommend Bishop b3 here
and then a six Queen e2 and rook b8
which is a pretty modern looking way of
playing against the the same issue Airy
Asian and here white has again on a huge
choice he can play in a very positional
fashion with rook c1 it's a good choice
if you want to want rather a slow game
so to say with maneuvering the point is
that simply b5 is answered by this and
you wouldn't pawn so black needs to
prepare this somewhere there should be 7
to cover six and then 91 which with the
idea of answering b5 with ease c5 and
this is an interesting maneuvering line
white um often continued with an eye to
f2 and even g3 Bishop g2 and castles
it's nice if you want to have a slow
positional battle the other completely
different approach that is worth looking
into is the old moves h4 which is I
think yeah well forgotten I think a lot
of players on might go for this line and
simply have forgotten how the theory is
really really going here blacks best is
to to stop it it's pretty similar to the
two the dragon actually two to go h5
after h4 and not allow Y to sacrifice a
pawn with h5 and then play might
continue night c1 to get the bishop
developed on f1e 5 d5 94 93 and now
black needs to really need to
sharpen up the play if he just takes on
b3 this is just nice for white the setup
on the kingside really makes it
difficult to go for f5 white has got the
half open a file and ideas of before at
c5 why does just somewhat better here
this has been confirmed in a lot of
games I think in the 80s so see fiber
cement move here also move which only
will be played by people really knowing
the line DC busy actually 94 84 bishop
deform and now you've won a pawn but
black has got some some counter ideas
with d5 of course this is also a line
you should study a bit before cdcd 597
and f4 this has been played recently by
think strong Chinese players I actually
forgot the name but white has I think a
nice position but it requires a little
bit of studying at home those h4 lines
but it's it's interesting because I
think a lot of players don't know the
specific stuff here and then white will
get a very very nice position
um another main move and I think it's
the most it's played the most is c5 then
white goes d5e 693 you need to develop
the bishop somehow and f1e takes d5 and
65 so you get this really nice
highlighted here a pawn chain from g2 to
d5 which is very stable and makes it
difficult for black to get some direct
play against you for pawn which is the
typical point of counter play in the
benoni
especially where white has just played
Knight f3
there is this spawn is just protected by
the night and here also I have you
always have the safe protection by the
f3 pawn play might continue Asics say
for that bt7
HB 2 and then very often black goes for
h5 to push the knight back from g3 then
go let's have a look Bishop g5 Queen c7
Queen e2 rook e8 castles 9 h7 Bishop h6
as a sample line if you want to want to
play this image variation in general
this one one player you need to study
the game which is a Russian Grand Master
and Alex Adria his I think I generated
over 2700 and he is I'm pretty sure the
world's biggest expert on this this
opening I think he's played dozens of
games in the same ish and he's gotten
all kinds of responses on move six there
also some some real ones and he's got
he's gotten this kind of benoni
I think know twenty thirty games or so
with great results
he beat some very strong players with it
for instance I think to power off
another strong grandmasters so it's
worth studying graves games if you if
you do that you will have a nice
repertoire in the same ish this is a
very good starting point to learn the
middle games because he really knows
what he's doing and has researched
everything so it's it's a good model
player to look at to study this opening
just quickly back to move six black has
some some of beat tries as well but
usually those are not so active in
regards to the center so
they're not especially dangerous but
still maybe an idea to look at one
tricky little move as a six this is
actually a line that I played myself
sometimes as black the 'dearest if white
goes for Bishop g5 to play something
like this c5 d 5b v 2 to get some sort
of Benko like compensation which is very
much playable for black y can of course
was proper research try to play for an
edge but black has got some counter play
and it's it's comparison to other lines
relatively easy to play so I would like
to suggest if someone really goes a six
to play Bishop e3 this also fits in
nicely with the suggestion of playing
also to e3 after 96 because black can
actually transpose back to this idea
here but mostly he will go for not be d7
here Queenie to c5 and now the point of
keeping the bishop on e3 instead of g5
is that Y does not really fast to play
d5 here you can just play rook to e1
queen a5 and now I to c1 this wouldn't
wouldn't be possible with the bishop on
g5 because then c4 would be nice for
black here um what I think just has a
somewhat better position it's not the
end of the world for black but white is
slightly better black doesn't have much
choice then sin taking here and then you
can just recapture with the bishop and
continue Knight to b3 Bishop e2 castles
end you've got the standard Marazzi bind
which is always I think a little bit
better for white
and it's not the typical Kings Indian
type of position where black gets active
plain so a six is not a huge problem but
it's good to know how to how to answer
this as a wrap-up of all the Kings
Indian lines that I presented which has
been h3 and Bishop g5 f4 as the sharpest
option and f3 as the main option one
important point is if you choose one of
these three lines you'll also have an
automatic response to the black playing
the Benoni d5e six and at this point
just according to the variation you play
against the Kings in Yin you either go
h3 Bishop g5 you go f4 or you go and
it's just a transposition black doesn't
have anything better than the ship g7
not GE to castles Nagi three four in
sand and it's just another way of
reaching the same position so it's um
it's a bit like killing two birds with
one stone
so your Kings Indian um variation also
provides you with a nice weapon against
a beam only you don't need to learn to
separate lines okay thanks for watching
um comments or questions
I welcome of course on youtube and if
you like the channel it's it's a good
idea to subscribe to it in order to get
notifications when new videos are
uploaded thanks and I continue soon with
new videos in the series